Okay, so the design of our class Movie, is
here on the top right, [SOUND] and I'm going
to begin, with a blank programming file. I have
named it, media.py, and it is saved inside a
folder called, movies. Now, to write a new class,
[SOUND] I will used the Python keyword, class. And
I will name it, Movie. You've probably notices, that
the first letter of the name of the class M,
is in uppercase. Now, this letter doesn't necessarily
need to be in uppercase, but, the Google style
guide for Python suggests that it should be.
Now, what is this thing called the Google style
guide for Python you ask, Well, let's Google
it. The first link here looks good to me.
Now, this Style Guide, provides conventions to programmers all
over the world. On how to write their programs.
If you scroll down a bit You will notice
that there are conventions on everything, from how to name
things, to how to write comments. By the way,
the link to this webpage, is available in the instructor
notes. I recommend that you read through this document.
If you click on this link called Naming, you will
notice that, when defining a class name, Google recommends that
the first letter of that name be in capital letters.
Okay, back to the code. Now, thus far, we've
encountered one new key word, called class. In fact, we
are going to come across several new words in this
lesson, and I want to list them all, in one
place for handy reference. The word class, is the first
one on that list. We will review, all the words
on this list before we end this lesson. So, you
may have noticed that our class, is empty thus far.
Now, to figure out what I want to do next
with it, I will go back to my design. So,
here I am, back with my class design. Now, I
know that eventually, I would want to create multiple instances
of the class movie. Instances like, Toy Story and
Avatar. I also know that I have previously created instances
of class Turtle. Instances like Brad, and to do that,
I had to write a piece of code that read,
turtle.Turtle, so I guess I will have to write a piece of code like
this, to create Toy Story, an instance of class Movie. Let's do that next.